what to use the most beautiful
speaking of hyenas uh what do you use
the most beautiful
nature inspired algorithm in your work
that you've come across
something maybe early on in your work or
maybe today
i i think it evolution computation is
the most amazing method so what
fascinates me
most is that with computers is that you
can
you can get more out than you put in i
mean you can write a piece of code
and your machine does what you told it i
mean
this happened to me in my freshman year
i it did something very simple and i was
just amazed i was blown away that it
would
it would get the number and it would
compute the result and i didn't have to
do it myself
very simple uh but if you push that a
little further
you can have machines that learn and
they might learn patterns
and already say deep learning neural
networks they can learn to recognize
objects sounds patterns that humans have
trouble with
and sometimes they do it better than
humans and that's so fascinating
and now if you take that one more step
you get something like evolution
algorithms
that discover things they create things
they come up with solutions that you did
not think of
and that just blows me away it's so
great that we can build
systems algorithms that can be in some
sense
smarter than we are that they can
discover solutions that we might miss
a lot of times it is because we have as
humans we have certain biases we expect
the solutions to be a certain way
and you don't put those biases into the
algorithm so they are more free to
explore
and evolution is just absolutely
fantastic explorer
and that's what what really is
fascinating yeah i think uh
i get made fun of a bit because i
currently don't have any kids
but you mentioned programs i mean
um do you have kids yeah so maybe you
could speak to this but there's a magic
to the creation of
creative process like i uh with spot
the boston dynamic spot but really any
robot that i've ever worked on
it just feels like the similar kind of
joy i imagine i would have as a father
not the same perhaps level but like the
same kind of wonderment like
exactly this which is like you know what
you had to do
initially to get this thing going uh
let's speak on the computer science side
like what the program looks like
but something about it uh doing
more than what the program was written
on paper
is like that somehow connects to the
magic
of this entire universe like that's
that's like
i i feel like i found god every time i
like it's like uh
because you're you've really created
something that's
living yeah even if it has a life of its
own has the intelligence of its own it's
beyond what you actually thought
yeah and that is i think it's exactly
spot on that's exactly what it's about
uh you created something and has a
ability to
uh live its life and and do good things
and um
you just gave it a starting point so in
that sense i think it's that may be part
of the joy
actually
you